ce qu'elle paraît le plus important et
le plus grave ce sont des choses qui
malheureusement ne font pas toujours la
première page des journaux je crois
qu'on commence à parler plus en plus
c'est la semaine l'usure et le
gaspillage de nos ressources là
l'appauvrissement du monde naturel le
maine est le dernier état du nord-est
des etats-unis avant le canada
marguerite yourcenar vite ici depuis 30
ans et même des visiteurs
les pales envie de recevoir que je suis
quelquefois forcé de fermer ma forme
les gens qui arrivent pour me demander
par exemple des conseils sur la
libération de manière de parvenir en
littérature d'éviter ces gens là et puis
j'ai aussi bien entendu des amis
aujourd'hui si nous sommes sur le lieu
de résidence de votre première maison
une petite petite cabane enfin très
agréablement placé auprès du taureau et
valeur ce torrent jeunes est entièrement
nettoyé moi même enlevons les troncs
d'arbres qui l'encombraient etc
c'était à ce moment-là motors j'ai même
essayé de l'acheter mais aussi les vont
compliquer une île pour la solitude
entre le ciel et la mer mais rattachés
aujourd'hui et depuis peu à la terre par
un point minuscule lille s'appelle le
mont désert ainsi baptisé par champlain
le navigateur alors je vous dis
eric nous avons en face à droite était
la prairie des jésuites ou d'un groupe
de jeunes vise 8 français avait débarqué
en si je ne me trompe 16 113 et on les
envoyer évangéliser le canada
marguerite yourcenar a choisi la
simplicité d'autres diraient la réalité
elle ne se dit pas écrivain c'est à dire
adeptes du monde littéraire mais elle
écrit depuis 50 ans connue depuis dix
ans seulement du grand public veut
balayer les feuilles mortes et votre jet
fabrique m'enfin je promène le chez elle
je téléphone à l'épicier
j'ouvre la porte et genre fera ses
voisins s'appelle les rockefeller
pourtant ici ce n'est plus l'amérique sa
maison s'appelle petite plaisance
maisons de bois rustique
cette année quatre ans que vous ayez une
maison aussi modeste ici voici les
ancêtres de marguerite yourcenar qu'elle
a regardé à la loupe dans son livre
archives du nord ancêtres paternels
familles flamandes les canes werk de cry
un coût qui ont traversé trois siècles
avant d'arriver à elle nous sommes les
descendants d'un million de personnes
dit marguerite yourcenar
il faut regarder les individus dans la
perspective du monde et non pas par
rapport à soi dit elle encore vous
écrivez en regardant la vie siècle passé
mais vous êtes un personnage du temps
présent ou 7 de weeds parra c'est une
expression qui ne peut vous arrêter
après tout on écrit pour être lu
mais en fait il est très naturel qu'elle
écrivait qu'il se place pas dans la mode
qui choisit de suivre sa ligne met un
certain temps à être lui a surtout va
être très dur
la solitude elle existe toujours quoi
qu'on fasse il ya les est même les plus
attachés les uns aux autres sensualité
où ils seront on est malade pour soi
même on est malheureux pour soi même se
dire que les autres n'entreront jamais
tout à fait même les plus même la
famille ou des amis les plus dévoués ne
comprennent pas très bien ce qui se
passe comme nous sommes malheureux et
mal à c'est à nous de nous sortir de
tout ça quand nous avons quitté
marguerite yourcenar la neige donc
venait de s'installer à petite plaisance
pour de longs mois dans 2 ou 3 ans
marguerite yourcenar écrira le troisième
chapitre de ce qu'elle a appelé le
labyrinthe du monde après souvenirs
vieux archives d'une heure ce sera quoi
l'éternité